eu queria agradecer o convite de estar
aqui
acho que eu vou falar um pouquinho
contar um pouco da história
sou professor da escola de uma escola
pública aqui no rio de janeiro na
taquara é a escola municipal francisco
raimi e também trabalha na rede
particular
tenho duas matrículas na rede municipal
de ensino
e pra contar essa história eu vou voltar
um pouco ao tempo e contar um pouco um
pouco da minha história minha trajetória
foi uma escola pública ea escola
municipal também é universidade pública
e eu retornei à escola que havia
estudado como professor é passar no
concurso modo como professor encontro é
um quadro igual ao quadro que eu tinha
saído nada havia mudado até o livro
didático era o mesmo que eu tenho que
utilizei quando foi aluno só que a gente
tinha outros problemas mais graves da
comunidade turma estavam mais cheias a a
violência já estava tomando mais conta
desses bairros dessas regiões que eram
consideradas áreas rurais e à
indisciplina e com tudo isso a escola
estava se tornando um local de difícil
acolher momento e trabalho a formação
que eu tive não me mostrou que eu iria
encontrar aquele quadro mas eu encontrei
outros professores que também estavam
angustiados com suas práticas e queriam
fazer uma educação pública diferentes de
qualidade que fizesse sentido na vida
das crianças
mas de que maneira a gente começou a
estudar a gente percebeu a construir
algo novo a gente aqui voltar a estudar
então a gente começou a se matricular em
cursos
em seguida por universidades de
capacitações que permitiram que a gente
pudesse levar a idéia é trazer para a
escola aplicar e discutir aquilo ali
então a gente estava em busca de uma
pedagogia de uma metodologia que fosse
nossa e daquela região daquela
comunidade
então fizemos isso depois a gente
percebeu que nós tínhamos que construir
o nosso caminho é o nosso percurso e com
isso nesse período surgiram as
olimpíadas de matemática
e quando a gente viu o problema da
olimpíada de matemática a gente percebeu
que ele vinha o encontro do que a gente
acreditava que era matemática que todo
mundo precisava ea gente resolveu
matricular e inscrevê-los né
na olimpíada e o resultado foi brilhante
foi maravilhoso
tivemos acho que seis alunos na ocasião
é premiados ea gente viu que o que
estávamos fazendo não era uma
experiência era algo que tinha sentido é
e mais do que nós estávamos fazendo
desde o início aqui a escola ela fica
ali na estrada do pau da fome bem
distante dali no bairro da pedra branca
é tem 900 alunos da educação infantil ao
9º ano não têm ensino médio e os alunos
são agrupados por níveis de habilidade
acho importante destacar aqui que
agrupados por níveis de habilidades
quando a gente recebe os alunos a gente
peça faz uma o diagnóstico do que ele
ainda não alcançou e matemática e ao
invés de pegar os alunos com muita
dificuldade e jogá los em salas é comum
ea gente agrupa aqueles alunos pelas
habilidades que eles ainda não têm
construídos
eles ainda não tenham construído ea
gente faz um trabalho em cima desse
grupo
a gente monta as seqüências didáticas
diferenciadas por exemplo aprender
sólidos geométricos a gente começa com
eles construindo independente do nível
de habilidade que eles estejam eles
constroem os sólidos que exerçam
atividades em grupo a gente viu que
quando trabalha se em grupo
o resultado é muito mais positivo do que
o trabalho individual é ensinar a raiz
quadrada que a gente às vezes decora e
tanta coisa na matemática a gente
recolhe usou pra nada nenhum eu como
professor
não sei onde eu ver aquela fórmula lá de
baixo que chama até hoje se alguém sabe
mas eu também ainda não sei para que
serve ainda não
eu sei que me deu possibilidade de
avançar em matemática para ver coisas
mais de cima mas eu não sei se um garoto
de 13 14 anos algumas coisas em
matemática fazem sentido nesse período e
nesse momento na vida deles
então vou aprender as quadrada mas
aprendeu o que quer de quadra que é um
número quadrado então a gente trabalha
muito com a aí com a lição quadrados que
eles constroem né
e daí eu vou tirar a partir da área país
vem de radicci que lado a lado do
quadrado num lado do quadrado radix
quadrado 16 ao lado num quadrado cuja
área 16 mas toda tudo que a gente tenta
ensinar um conceito que faça sentido na
vida deles e que têm alguma aplicação
foi a folha se meteria a gente hoje
graças a esse trabalho eu terminei o
mestrado foi um grupo de doutorado
o trabalho de olimpíadas trabalho com
essas crianças de metodologia ea gente
sabe que a gente tem que ter um
currículo de horizonte
a gente tem que ensinar algo hoje que
ele que a gente entenda que vai fazer
sentido lá na frente se eu não entendo
que aquilo vai fazer sentido
não tem nem por quê ensinar então assim
simetria importante é para você aprender
números relativos que são números
negativos e positivos tem assimetrias
meteria dos números a simetria espacial
então ele tem que construir simetria mas
ele tem que ver o que é simetria né
não é só falar em simetria ele tem
percebeu que a simetria
então é isso alguns trabalhos jogos
assim esses alunos que foram agrupados
com algumas habilidades não construídas
eu percebi junto com esse grupo que
através de jogos você consegue é ter
acesso às dificuldades do aluno com
muito mais forte muito mais facilidade
então os jogos entraram para você tentar
resgatar o amor ao invés de passar uma
lista de exercício é mecânica é só para
instrumentalizar eu posso construir um
jogo onde ele vai aplicar aqueles
conceitos ea gente vai discutir o que
pode ser feito ali então jogos entraram
pra com um sentido de resgatar aqueles
alunos que tinham já uma barreira com a
matemática e que tinha algumas
dificuldades em lidar com essa matéria
lhe esse é um jogo onde eles vão
aprender a somar e subtrair números
negativos eles ainda não aprenderam
então a gente tem que montar um circuito
é os dois levam a vitória porque
antigamente a gente fazia um negativo
perdi o positivo ganhava no negativo
também ganha é porque é negativo que vai
perder então os dois sentidos agora há a
ideia seguinte saiu mas o número
positivo faz você avançar um número
negativo faz você retroceder
então eu não filmei ainda o conceito de
adição de inteiros mas ele sabe que se
atira mais três - dois vai falar é só
dar um passo à frente é avançar 1 ele
está somando números inteiros está
somando números negativos sem eu ter
falado em adição de números negativos
depois a gente discute e e aí a gente
vai é fundamental aqueles conceitos em
cima daquelas discussões e aquelas
aquilo que ele percebeu durante o
processo do jogo
então o jogo tem que não jogo por 1 jogo
é o jogo pós a porque o jogo é legal e
lúdico não jogo tem que ter uma
matemática por trás do jogo
a temática quer alcançar com ele através
daquele jogo
eu tenho que entender que aquele jogo
tem que fazer sentido tem que ser algo
que construa o conhecimento é aqui
eles tiveram que criar porque a gente
acha eu acho a gente assim eu acredito
que a linguagem é fundamental no ensino
em qualquer área então eles pegaram um
papelão papelão de caixa é de caixa de
mantimentos de e ele estiver que tinham
que construir um jogo da memória com
decodificação e codificação de
expressões algébricas esse jogo foi
construído por uma turma com tinha um
nível de habilidade menor tinham mais
deficiência
agora algumas pessoas pode pressionar
mas o aluno que está numa turma com
nível de um nível de habilidade menor
ele pode se sentir pior não está numa
turma que tem eu tenho os alunos
premiados tanto no em todas as turmas
tanto numa turma com algumas habilidades
deficientes como aquela turma que tem
alunos com maior nível de habilidade
então agora a gente tem dois premiados
numa turma que vem acompanhando quando
os alunos têm muita dificuldade a gente
monta um projeto eles não são retidos
eles vão seguir até o final do ano sem
reprovação não ea gente vai tentando
construir isso ao longo do caminho mas
se a gente construindo algo que
realmente eficiente até o resultado uma
olimpíada acontece há mais a esse aluno
ele é colocado em outra turma não falo
não é colocar em outra turma
por que esse aluno continuam fazendo o
trabalho de casa continua e no passeio
bastante gosto muito de beijar na boca
fora da idade que a gente não acredita
que seja mas já é mas são alunos que
estão desenvolvendo um conceito de
matemática que podem ser aplicado onde
ele queira e aqueles também construíram
a estão construídos por eles
alguns fazem coisas alguns trabalhos em
ter disciplinar na copa que você está
trabalhando geometrias foram feitos por
eles não dá
fala aí eles tinham que pegar construir
com um prego é um quadro da copa de
alguns países se fala geometria
paralelismo polígonos que tinham ali
montar um powerpoint falar um pouco
sobre a cultura daquele país
então misturava matemática artes e
geometria é aqui são os sólidos que
depois eles fizeram com a técnica de
mondrian
fale um pouco sobre mondrian e eles
construíram em tamanhos maiores os
sólidos e ficarão em exposição no
colégio né
e aí a gente aprende um pouco da
história da arte um pouquinho de
matemática também aí aqui vai ter um
vídeo porque por exemplo é quando eu vou
da geometria área eu trabalhando agora a
área perímetro não vou ficar falando que
a área de um quadrado é lá do
comprimento e largura perímetro a soma
dos lados
então a idéia de você montar projetos eu
peço que eles façam uma planta baixo
mostra mostrei para eles o que é uma
planta baixa de uma casa de uma casa de
um quarto sala cozinha banheiro
eles precisam é fazer uma planta de uma
casa é buscar material quanto custo
material para revestimento de piso
quanto ele vai precisar em cada cômodo
ele pode pesquisar na internet uma loja
de material de construção o piso que ele
vai utilizar pegar com o pedreiro custo
da mão de obra e apresentar o grupo
aquele projeto ele tenda usando o
conceito de proporcionalidade não é
fazer tudo dentro da sua proporção ea
gente vai fazer nesse projeto durante um
mês até que eles apresentam para a turma
quer dizer eles vão aprender muito mais
homem teria do que eu ficar falando pra
ele sobre a área
no quadro num quadro que diz o piloto
que a área é o produto do comprimento
vezes a largura de um retângulo esse
vídeo eles fizeram falta pouco e civis
fizeram eles construíram um
não tem um pau de self eu chamei de pau
de teodolito eles pegaram uma madeira um
cabo de vassoura prenderam um celular e
eu baixei o teor do light é um celular
que você vê a angulação então é usar a
tecnologia dentro de sala de aula sal a
tecnologia para algo que faça sentido
ele tem que usar tecnologia sim tem que
usar o celular ele tem que entender que
aqui é uma ferramenta importante e eles
tinham que medir a distância para quem
pegou o metrô ea gente a gente tomar uma
surra no ensino médio estudando aquela
trigonometria você não entende nem que o
mais importante é que aquilo ali serve
pra você medir espaços e distâncias e
que prováveis nós fizemos na escola eles
tinham que me dê alguma coisa fora da
escola e trazer um vídeo apresentar pra
turma mostrar o tamanho do prédio
a nossa improvisação é o único caso no
mundo que não tenho acho que em casa deu
assim aproximadamente ambos entram em 60
61 62 10 10
tá bom então tranquilo
ele faz dizem tem um tamanho do teu do
livro é uma idéia gente contou o valor
deste espaço
[Música]
a gente pediu para treinar gente vai ter
quatro colocado nela juros era 17
guichês funcionam naquela parada espaço
legal que eles foram pedir depois na
casa de 1 e viram que o valor dava
certinha e eles ficam surpresas para que
aquilo funciona aquela parada
claro que aquela parada funciona né a
ideia era essa escola é nesse processo a
escola tem 225 medalhas nas quatro
olimpíadas que a gente participa da
obmep que a brasileira da escola pública
o méxico e estadual a cargo do que
internacional e ao bn são 425 premiações
para alunos de 12 professores 29 para a
escola ea idéia é resgatar essa semana o
resultado estadual tem mais 40 alunos
que não estão ali computados
eu gosto dessa frase sempre me pareceu
estranho que todos aqueles que estudam
seriamente essa ciência acabam tomados
de uma espécie de paixão pela mesma
liberdade que seguir o que proporciona o
máximo prazer ao conhecimento e
aprendizagem não é a posse mas aquisição
na presença mas o ato de atingir lamento
acho que a idéia é essa a olimpíada
ficou o final porque a olimpíada no
fundo é um pretexto para que eles
percebam que possam construir um futuro
promissor
através da educação pública e de
qualidade
essa idéia
[Aplausos]